ils ne bougeront pas depuis trois jours
les agriculteurs du loir-et-cher bloque
la sous-préfecture de romorantin
ils protestent contre le nouveau
découpage des fds les zones défavorisées
simples avec ce nouveau zonage deux
tiers des agriculteurs en sologne
perdraient leurs subventions
des aides qui peuvent être un 8000 euros
par exploitation et par an
depuis hier des élus locaux et nationaux
portent leurs revendications jusqu'à
paris là on a recent sollicité
l'ensemble des politiques les députés
les sénateurs les conseillers
départementaux et tous les élus parce
que les mères mardi soir était avec nous
ici devant la sous préfecture
donc depuis mardi on est jour et nuit
ici et on ne repartira que quand on aura
ce qu'on veut plusieurs parlementaires
du loiret a été reçu aujourd'hui à
l'elysée ils ont alerté le président
macron sur la situation des agriculteurs
ils ont aussi plaidé pour que la sologne
tout entière reste considéré comme zone
défavorisée
le député du loir et cher guillaume
pelletier lui n'était pas à paris mais
il a pris le temps d'aller à la
rencontre des paysans de sa
circonscription
on a besoin de nos agriculteurs c'est
très important que nous on soit tous
mobilisés et soudés pour les défendre et
j'ai décidé ce matin d'écrire une lettre
solennelle au ministre de l'agriculture
en lien et je proposerai c'est peut-être
évidemment aux autres parlementaires de
loir-et-cher pour qu'ils prennent enfin
cette décision politique
hier dans la région occitanie les
agriculteurs ont obtenu gain de cause
sur la question des zones défavorisées
une décision qui nourrit l'espoir des
paysans solognot ils seront fixés sur
leur sort le 15 février